an important visit at a critical time
rafael grossi the director general of
the international atomic energy agency
arrived in tehran on saturday ahead of
iran's plan
to partly suspend his agency's
inspections
of its nuclear facilities early on
sunday
grocery sat down with the head of iran's
atomic energy organization
to discuss what happens next to his
inspectors
the director general also met foreign
minister javad zarif
before heading back to vienna
and the outcome of those meetings is
that the iaea
reached a temporary bilateral technical
understanding with iranian officials
which will allow the agency to continue
its monitoring of tehran's nuclear
program
the hope of the iaea has been to be able
to stabilize
a situation which was very unstable
and i think this technical
understanding does it
so that other political consultations at
other levels
can take place and most importantly we
can avoid
a situation in which we would have been
in practical terms flying blind
officials have said as of february 23
iran will no longer abide by the
additional protocols
of the non-proliferation treaty because
the united states left the 2015 nuclear
deal
and imposed tough new economic sanctions
on iran's oil and banking sector
this decision is part of a bill which
parliament passed in december
in an attempt to force the united states
to lift some of those sanctions
and return to the nuclear deal foreign
minister javad zarif is not optimistic
anything will happen before that
deadline nothing has changed
biden claims that
trump's policy of maximum pressure was
maximum failure
lincoln also just recently said that
that policy failed
but for all practical purposes they're
pursuing the same policy
they haven't changed that policy the new
restrictions mean
iaea inspectors will no longer be
allowed to make surprise visits to any
of iran's
six declared nuclear facilities and they
won't have access to any other sensitive
or military sites either they will also
be denied access
to the 24-hour surveillance cameras at
those sites
with less than four months left in
office the rouhani administration was
hesitant
at first to implement the bill which had
passed in parliament
but after the endorsement of the supreme
leader the president had no choice
now the government is hoping that the
new administration in washington will
lift some of the sanctions
which have cost iran an estimated one
trillion dollars
or president rouhani's eight-year term
will end with a failed nuclear deal
and a crumbling economy dorsochabari
al-jazeera tehran